so this is a work in progress report on
a project that Charles and I are working
on a couple of other people we're
looking at statistically solving because
I like alliteration statistically
solving sneezes and sniffles step by
step and so particularly this is a work
in progress right we haven't solved this
problem what we giving you an update as
to where we are so who are we well you
know that I'm the co-chair for the
conference and I've been an industrial
data scientist for 15 years and my
colleague jars here Charles a
bioinformatician turned data scientist
to understand any more about C or should
I introduce any more than that yeah it's
real good right okay i'm the author of
high-performance python that'll be one
of the books that we're signing this
lunchtime and super excited that a
colleague is brought in my japanese and
my polish translations that turned up a
few days ago apparently I'm not signing
those but if you happen to be not an
English reader you can get in Japanese
and polish so I run model in sight my
business partner Chris and I here so we
do machine learning consulting Charles
works with us and our current client is
in Dava and they were good enough to be
a gold sponsor for us so please go and
speak to the endeavor stand and the guys
understand over in the far corner
they've got USB lights and things to
give away so don't have a chat with them
about being scared industrialized data
science that's fine so my wife sneezes a
lot and I've got a graph in a minute she
sneezes a lot could be close the door at
the back place is quite noisy out there
either we need to shuffle forwards
Annabelle because you could you middle
lot shuffle forward a bit that's all
right we can we can shuffle in and
there's some room at the front here as
well to do the shuffle room it's a bit
like the rowing boat song just sit there
and you know totally it's not it's
really it's not cool
I guess keep coming forwards keep coming
for you come sit on my shoulder she'll
be fine it's room there and there's room
there ki coming in yeah 3 down there
it's three down there keep coming
forward if you want you want okay please
come forward there's still more coming
in so you're at the back please come to
the front let's make it easy good grief
we might facilitate the door straight in
a minute hey coming forward keep coming
forward well man yeah right we did run a
survey to see which talks are most
popular and this one and the one in the
other room vied for equal popularity so
I chose to stay in this room that one's
pretty popular too yeah well it sucks
being a popular conference but thank you
for bearing wins so my wife sneezes a
lot I've got a graph with a minute to
show you how much he sneezes she's also
an iOS developer so she develops iphone
apps and we ask the question so she's
been sneezing for 20 years we asked the
question a couple of years ago hey
couldn't we use machine learning and
some clever data science to try to
understand the root factors behind the
sneezing so what drives the allergy so
that's the that's the top line goal sold
my wife sneezes so one person sneezes
but the more general goal is could we
reduce symptoms for people so could be
could be for other people who sneeze
provide a generalized framework whereby
they can record their own symptoms be it
sneezing or other allergic reactions and
then gather external data and figure out
some kind of relationship so someone is
better informed as to what causes them
to sneeze be in a particular kind of hay
fever from a grass or a tree pollen
rather than just generalized hay fever
or a food allergy or various things and
and at which point could be possibly
reduce people's need for medication that
was like a really important endgame can
we reduce a person's reliance on using
medication so about thirty percent or so
a ten to thirty percent to the Western
population is affected by allergic
rhinitis that's not when my wife has
gone so allergic rhinitis that's
traditional hay fever or ser cat allergy
and I'm going to extrapolate and wave my
hands and say that's around
one-and-a-half billion people around the
world probably suffer from allergic
rhinitis and so probably more for
rhinitis in general and this is
interesting and important because some
antihistamines it
they are now being linked to conditions
like Alzheimer's so it'll be nice if we
could help people take less of this
medication to make their lives better
and to give them a better chance of not
getting weird complications later in
life so my wife's needs is a lot this is
a count of number of sneezes and number
of days she has those me sneezes it's
it's rare that she sneezes zero times in
a day it's quite likely she sneezes one
time in a day that's the number of days
for one stayed in the day quite likely
she's easy bear sneezes two times or
three or four up to ten times a day so
there are many days of the year in the
last year's worth of a recorded data
where she sneezes that many times up to
26 times in a day and this is with and
without antihistamine for half the year
she's taking an antihistamine and half
the year without its roughly day on day
off so it's roughly an equal balance
data set in terms of antihistamine usage
so these sneeze counts are either with
medication which reduces the prevalence
of sneezing or without medication so
there's a lot of sneezes so we formed a
hypothesis Ian's wife emily suffers from
non-allergic rhinitis we say
non-allergic she was diagnosed by a
doctor years ago with chronic persistent
allergic rhinitis so she sneezes because
she comes into contact with some kind of
allergy in like a cat or hay fever
however she sneezes all year round as
you'll see it's not seasonal we've
removed conditions like the cat or even
me as some people have pointed out
because she's been traveling around the
world so doesn't cease because of me or
because of the house or because of our
street or because of our cat she's had
it for 20 years so and she's an advanced
pattern recognition machine like we all
are and she can't spot any obvious
simple patterns it's not a trivial
condition it's probably a multi-factor
condition and it could well be both
allergic so hay fever and non-allergic
things like whether for example so we
have some hypothesis possibly it's word
related that's a driver for some people
with non-allergic rhinitis alcohol might
make things worse she's self reports
that when she drinks beer in the evening
she's more likely to sneeze off the
would suck can we get data to support
that when we lived in Chile the
pollution was awful and she had a bigger
problem when we're living in Chile so
maybe pollution is a factor so we need
to get data to answer
these questions so here's how we
gathered our data as i mentioned emily
is an iOS developer so she wrote an app
to do this so she's written a nap it's
open source on this github account so
you can grab this and run this she's got
nice buttons where she logs the symptoms
so we get sub-second accuracy with the
GPS log as to where and when she has the
symptom be that a sneeze or watery eye
irritated nose coughing a whole bunch of
symptoms mainly sneezing or use of
antihistamine in the app you can see
what the logs look likes at the time the
location location changes the iOS just
records for you whenever you move
location it has a new stamp saying
you've moved location you were here
you'll now over here well gone oh she
sneezes politely but ya know it sir
there is no attempt to suppress a sneeze
no yes she sneezes yeah this is a lot as
you'll see she yeah there's a good
reason to try and solve this oh what the
i was in the room no no no no so we we
don't record that i'm in the room or not
but we just know that when emily is out
of the country she has the same
prevalence of antihistamine usage and
sneezes so we've isolated me it almost
entirely we don't know if it requires
several wash cycles to take possible
allergens out of clothing which might
still be on her clothing when she's
traveling we're pretty sure that's not
the case but there are some rough edges
so some data issues Apple being Apple
have a slightly different day time
format it's got a different epoch date
so it's not the 1970s unique eat pork
it's 2001 with a different day offset
which coincides or something to do with
next step and so we switched sensibly
after discovering this to ISO 8601 so
Oracle today times in ISO 8601 if you go
underground the phone confidently
reports it has a location it's at gps 00
which is off the coast of Nigeria so we
have to do some fixes for that
afterwards and ered in hindsight there
was a weak experimental design Emily's
recording positive incidences of a thing
so I have sneezed I've taken alcohol if
she doesn't record sneezes does it mean
she didn't sneeze or she forgot
to sneeze sneeze issued sneezes enough
that we get enough data regardless of
whether she misses one but say but
alcohol use maybe we miss a critical
factor so we think a day has no alcohol
when there was one alcohol so this
positive experiment this positive data
experimental design in hindsight is a
bit weak but that's hard to get beyond
that and really start annotating
someone's exact life so this to remind
you again my wife sneezes a lot from one
time a day through to 26 times a day and
takes antihistamine every other day kind
of a balanced data set for a
classification task you might consider
so this is data self logged by Emily
this is a one-year trace of data this is
the number of sneezes per day so it's
just a line chart bouncing up and down
you can see that really are there zero
sneezes per day it's about roughly one
every eight days every other day has
some number of sneezes per day up to 26
in the middle of November so I get a
really good trace so we we now record
cold and it might well be the case of
that was a cold and then that will be
the third condition of rhinitis
infectious rhinitis when you sneeze
because you've got a cold so that could
well be an outlier absolutely and we now
as part of our evolving experimental
design we now record whether there's a
cold or medication for colds like
sudafed so we can isolate those kind of
outliers ah yes good point so may is may
is because we have missing data we have
missing data because emily performed a
beta upgrade on her iOS code and it
hopefully deleted everything today you
want to be a new iOS developer so we
just got to trash your system and we do
we didn't want to warn you with that you
didn't want to check your head your
backups so deleted everything so after
much scrabbling around we realized we'd
lost five days but only five days but
still five days and that was very
frustrating and for both of us and a
professional level it was really quite
embarrassing to lose five days of data
early in the experiment but nonetheless
it was it was annoying so after that we
switched to using segments do I owe as
an online backup as well Sybil erm data
is low two segments io as well as an
off-site backup effectively and this
kind of barcode ething down here this is
a bar if an antihistamine is taken and
it's white if there is no idea
taken so you can see there are periods
when there's compressed blue there's
lots of antihistamines being taken and
periods of white and that's when there
were no antihistamines being taken so
you get kind of this way you've like
effect you can see that there are there
are times when there remind histamines
and fewer antihistamines and a quick
break down some of this data so this is
Monday through Sunday so Monday Tuesday
Wednesday done to the weekend and then
hours of the day Emily sneezes at 8am we
wake up Emily sits up she sneezes and
that's just that's just a morning thing
can see this monday through friday and
then saturday and sunday we wake up
later so she sneezes later but she still
sneezes and then in the evening she
sneezes as well and at the beginning we
thought there was some kind of pattern
in there but as we've got as we've
gained more data it looks fairly
consistent and she's needs his Lester in
the day we don't know what drives that
but that's that's a pattern that's very
consistent in the data sorry so we
change the mattress we've and when she's
been traveling shoes of course change
flat or change department so for up to
three weeks at a time and they can be
symptoms are the same and we did wonder
if it was dust mites everyone has dust
mites they live in all of our clothing
and beds and furniture you can desiccate
them by taking the apartment down to
fifty percent humidity we did that for
three months symptoms didn't change so
don't think it's that antihistamine
usage so le wakes up she sneezes is
going to be a bad day she think she has
an antihistamine in the morning she
tends not to happen during the day or
she has them in the evening if the
symptoms have been really bad this begs
an interesting experimental question is
the morning use of antihistamine because
of yesterday's symptoms or because of
what she thinks is happening today and
if we're trying to do a prediction task
are we predicting today's morning's I've
just woken up and feel guaty
antihistamine usage the end of the day
that's pretty clearly from the day's
worth of exposure to stuff but the
morning one we don't know and we get
different results depending on how we
model that so there's an open question
there if you've ever thought about this
from your kind of work I'd be interested
in your feedback it's needed an
antihistamine there is a relationship
between them and so medication and we've
resaw and put over three days so if in
three days three antihistamines are
taken we're looking at the column with
the three in it and then the y-axis is
the number of sneezes on those
so on a day with us around three days
with no antihistamines in total there
are a few sneezes over those three days
on three days with three antihistamine
to an antihistamine every day there are
lots of sneezes and the mean is hired
the mean goes down down down so it looks
like there's a relationship between
sneezes and medication it turns out
antihistamines we do sneezing they don't
get rid of it and so we see this
positive relationship and here I've used
seabourn flipped it around and we use
number of sneezes in a linear regression
to predict number of medications taken
over three days here we just draw a line
through it and it looks fine later on we
validate this using cross-validation to
check it is a true predictive
relationship but it is this is just a
nice diagram to show that there is a
relationship some antihistamines work
but they don't work completely one
questioned Emily posed is how long does
an antihistamine last for so can she
time her usage of an antihistamine for
best effect when she's got something
coming up in the day and potentially you
might want to try and to histamine a
like loratadine that she uses was
something else jaws cetirizine is that
the right name for one of the other
popular ones so yet maybe she wants to
use another one it have a different
half-life on a different effect and a
different time to become effective and
then become ineffective so you could
gather this kind of dated data to check
the effectiveness of different
medications so here if Emily took an
antihistamine in the morning so between
6am and 10 am i marked as a point in
time and then for the next 12 hours I
look at the number of sneezes per hour
so here we have 67 antihistamine such 67
traces drawn in an alpha really alpha
shaded line so it's 12 for 12 hours
worth of 123 whatever antidote sneezes
after an antihistamine and if we sum all
of these together then we get this blue
plot here and what's interesting is in
the zeroth hour of take an antihistamine
sneezes are high on the first hour
sneezes are high on the second hour
sneezes a low turns out rata dean takes
two hours to become fully dissolved into
the body and to become effective and
then it's low for a number of hours for
about nine hours afterwards and then
after that sneeze potential for sneezing
increases and we see the number of
sneezes going up
and so it's worn off after about nine
hours of being fairly effective and if
we simulate that the dashed line of the
background if we simulate the
antihistamine dispersal in the body
takes two hours to get fully dispersed
and it's got an eight hour half life two
every eight hours it halves in strength
and then that's it this simulated line
here and it drops off so we get some
idea as to for Emily on a very personal
way what level of antihistamine is
effective and ineffective in her body
and that's going to vary by individual
so here we've got nice direct evidence
because not calibrating dosages of
loratadine if we want it on a personal
level another question is does alcohol
increase the propensity to sneeze Johnny
you're just joining the room Jon seda Oh
John they walk so I've been chatting
with Rose people about this including
John and I couldn't answer this to my
satisfaction with my ability with stats
I was unhappy with the way I modeled
things I had a chat with Jon oh well
that's a zero boosted Poisson
distribution really you should be using
pi mc3 I don't know pi MC three houses
John you give me an excuse to play with
your data so i gave my death of john and
a few days ago he'd turned around the
model and so he gave me this model I
don't understand it yeah it occurred
when I was organized in the conference
oh I haven't looked at it but he tells
me that he thinks we can say that
whether an antihistamine is taken or not
if alcohol was used in the evening the
propensity for sneezes after the alcohol
goes up so it looks like sneezes are
more likely if alcohol was taken and you
can shake your head and I agree that I
don't trust this data yet one of the
problems is bad data collection
methodology Emily used myfitnesspal to
record exactly the type of alcohol and
the number she was taken to a red wine
and the number of them or she used the
app to say I had alcohol and she
normally did it but not always so we
didn't always get the right data so we
are now proposing a new experiment three
months of consistent data gathering so
we can answer this properly over the
Charles
oh by the way on purpose so learning
relationships so as Ian mentioned
conveniently our data set is split
approximately fifty fifty that Emily
uses an antihistamine on in half of the
days and the date set so it makes a very
convenient target for a binary
classification problem we we've observed
seasonal trends in the data as you'd
expect you know you have temperature
changes that are obvious throughout the
year there are lots of other seasonal
trends we want to look at environmental
factors for the day and today's
proceeding the day that we're trying to
predict and not look at these not to get
too distracted by these seasonal trends
so we haven't done much in the way of
time series analysis we want an
interpretable model simply as good so if
we can use logistic regression we'll do
that we don't want to over complicate
things how do we get to the next right
then look over your shoulder ok so we
grab data from various sources we use
the are where the data package to get
the weather daily weather data for
London City Airport incidentally this
package now refuses to play so a Python
equivalent may be in the offing so that
gets us probably a couple of dozen
columns of weather data some of which
may or may not be missing but it's
pretty useful stuff we've also grabbed
pollution data from the London air
website that includes Knox particulates
and again it's a useful data set but we
would observe caution sorry suggest
caution we've observed quite a variation
between sampling from the different
stations and in particular there's it
seems to be a lot of missing data which
we think is caused by
bro consensus relationships with the
antihistamine usage there well we've so
we've got a 5-day moving average of the
mean humidity on the Left plot versus
number of antihistamines taken over that
five-day period it's quite difficult to
to eyeball these relationships but
sometimes we think we see something and
the scatterplot there we we can see that
there may be some sort of relationship
for that particular factor we've we've
run these graphs for everything and we
see these weak relationships and we hope
that so that gives us some confidence
that we can build a model around it so
feature augmentation we've used pandas
extensively to shift the data and create
rolling means for varying numbers of
days preceding the day where we're
trying to predict if emma is taking
antihistamine we've got the alcohol
consumption from Emily's app and also
scraped from My Fitness Pal data
resampled to daily unfortunately neither
data source is complete and My Fitness
Pal is it's difficult to to craft regex
that are sensitive to actual alcohol
consumption because all the entries are
the name of the product and not just a
nice boolean of alcohol that's taken bus
an underground usage data Ian scraped
from the online oyster payments site so
I think did you PDF it and yeah so it's
PDF tanned then scraped so that's very
useful if for instance you want to know
whether she's traveled on Northern Line
which was one of the things we looked
into because we thought it was pretty
dirty and plots of particulates down
there
and so that lock together gave us a
dataframe with 84 features to work with
and to really get stuck into with the
machine learning so back to in all right
I just get this start work on
and that sounds okay yep perfect so we
have 84 features there's about 20 raw
data features that we're recording and
then we've created as Charles saying
created lots of synthetic data off of
that so moving averages standard
deviations overtime directionality by
change of moving average over time so
we've got 84 features 330 rose is a tiny
data problem the average including
movement changes it's probably 50 but it
really boils down to whether an
antihistamine was taken that's a log and
number of sneezes per day or are you
talking about the weather data right so
yeah that's a very small number just
those war events and then the location
changes Emily's going around a lot
there'll be a lot of those but typically
30 40 a day so we're talking thousands
of our tens of thousands of events max
in a year for one person so we then
built some a variety of models logistic
regression great and random forests and
support vector machines at radial basis
functions because that's what everyone
in medical does and this was all going
to be great right only it turns out
everything seemed to fall away so we
could build some complex models and get
sort of seventy eighty percent
predictive accuracy allegedly with lots
of features but the more I look to them
are these features are rubbish this
doesn't make any sense I've got to be
realistic here we're making synthetic
features and it looks like there are
just enough coincidental relationships
in the synthetic feature and the actual
signal we're trying to measure that
something's coming through and is
apparently predictive in the data we've
got but it's not going to hold up in the
future so that's rubbish that's never
going to work so I started peeling all
of this back one step at a time and then
we kept on coming back to the fact that
sneezes per day were predictive this is
under cross-validation and whether the
previous day and antihistamine was used
if it was used yesterday it's less
likely to be used today and vice versa
and those are our best predictive
features so great this doesn't explain
anything really really unhelpful and
what's wrong with the data and then I
got to thinking about what these this
data comes from London City Airport
we've got external weather data
Lucien data from around London a lot of
the day Emily's in an air-conditioned
office so she's not subject to the
external weather data so in the summer
hi summer not so exposed to it and in
the winter earlier in heated buildings
and heated homes totally disconnected
data set from what's observed on the
runway at london city airport so that's
a problem so what if we look only at
eight call to August when emily was not
working for any particular client and
she was consulting and traveling around
london and working from home and we live
in a Victorian apartment with single
glazed windows so the internal
temperature is fairly and humidity and
the like is fairly representative of the
outside whether they were observing well
it turns out we get some predictive
features and this is kind of exciting so
sneeze is a medication per day so he'll
be looking at logistic regression and
we're looking at the coefficients inside
them and here I've summarized 5,000
independent models to see how stable the
coefficients are and that's why I'm
using a boxplot there's a couple of
outliers shown forgot 5,000 models all
the matters really is that for a
logistic regression model we could
assume that the the most useful
coefficient for any feature is the main
site so strong positive coefficient for
sneezes the more sneezes there are the
more likely an antihistamine is for
medication previous that's a negative
coefficient so if an antihistamine was
taken yesterday this being a negative
coefficient it's less likely a
antihistamine will be taken today for
mean humidity seven days that's a seven
day moving average of the mean humidity
of the outside world negative
relationship so they hire the humidity
that damper it is the less likely an
antihistamine is this is kind of
interesting turns out that low humidity
dry air dries out your nasal lining and
that can give you a prevalence in the
increase of sneezing and sea level
pressure reliably comes through I don't
know why I don't know what that means
yet and I'll get to that in a minute and
so that was the model this is it super
simple model but it seems to explain
something but do we trust it well we
don't know I can form some hypotheses
about how to proceed this year and i
hope the data supports the hypotheses we
don't know we're not concluding anything
at this stage so also in the last year
we can look at weekends Emily's not in
the office at weekends and it turns out
if I rebuild the model for weekends only
actually the relationship seemed to
stand up so we think we've got something
particularly with the humidity so that's
really quite exciting so we want to see
if that carries on this year
I mentioned that we were evolving our
approach so we've we're logging a better
alcohol experiment more consistently now
to try and get the right data for that
and at home have got loads of sensors
like for example with blue air home
hygrometer and this is a dampness in the
air humidity recorded in the hygrometer
along with temperature and particulates
separately I've got a dialogue 1100 Pro
costing 400 pound which is an
industrially calibrated particular
counter and with a bit of a difficult
interface and a bunch of other sensors
so we're really trying to log the home
environment to go to model up out of
that and we've used a portable
hygrometer in Emily's office and we know
that it's roughly forty percent humidity
in the Mozilla office and so we can
start to interpolate another part of the
day from that to add that to the
modeling and also move house well
actually we're planning to move house
this year so if we move house to get a
totally different environment in a
different bit of London outside of North
London and kentish town where the
pollution is high going down south of
London where the pollution is much lower
maybe we'll see some different behavior
there that could be interesting so next
steps we're getting our second year of
data this is really exciting and we've
invited a couple of people to join the
trials so we've got several other people
logging their data with different
symptoms and different drivers but all
around allergic and non-allergic
rhinitis so we're going to get different
sets of data and if you suffer from this
or someone you know suffers from this
and you're interested in joining the
trial then I'd love to have a chat about
this is well we're on a few more people
I kind of want ten or so for this next
year so we can stay on top of it we're
keeping the data private but not
publishing it so Emily's allowed me to
talk about this we're not giving the
data away I don't want to give away date
GPS traces of everyone's life that'll be
a really bad thing even though Google
and Apple have all of this of course but
I don't want to be stopped loading it's
the internet and so if you're interested
in that come and have a chat with me one
thing we can do is regress rather than
classify true or false antihistamine
usage for a day what if we turn it into
a three-day resample where we count the
number of antihistamines over several
days and we incorporate several days
worth of humidity into say a mean or
something else and then we regress on a
three day challenge so we look at the
problem very differently I've got a
question for you for anyone who's
particularly strong with your underlying
stats and logistic regression logistic
regression assumes independent and
identically distributed data and we're
using a time series that we've randomly
shuffled but today's weather is
you're nodding nodding nodding shaking
nodding can we chat afterwards right so
we know that our data is not independent
and identically distributed yesterday's
weather is the best predictor of today's
weather unless you've got a very complex
model there are strong relationships
there pragmatically this works
cross-validation says this is good but
we're busting some of the underlying
assumptions so if anyone's thought hard
about this I've tried to think about it
I don't know if you've got feedback I'd
love to hear it and another thing is
we're testing on randomized days which
shuffled days and then we do cross
validation and instead one thing we can
do is just take time as a series train
on say two months and then test a week
ahead slide forward a week test on two
months test than a week afterwards so
there are other ways we can test the
data but i'm pretty sure from previous
experiment this is going to hold up and
we've also been introduced to some very
strong academic research groups now so
now we can get some academics you really
know this problem to come and help us to
interpret the model proposed new
experiments and propose new ways of
gathering data and obviously a final
potential research as strap not just
sent us to the house but also to the
wife very exciting she's less excited by
that possibility but it turns out there
is devices like the app mochi it's a
small bluetooth device you put it onto
your bag it reports by bluetooth
pollution in real time and other
environmental data that you're carrying
on your backpack so this will give us a
much higher fidelity model of my wife's
environment of five meters squared
around her that could be really
interesting so that's where we are with
that right it's a challenging problem we
thought we would find some stronger
relationships more readily instead after
three four five six months worth of much
hand-wringing and shouting at the sky we
found one signal that we trust that's
great we found a signal array but I want
to find more than one so we've got to do
more work we think we can answer borna
we can answer how effective is an
antihistamine loratadine in this case
for my wife's case we can't yet answered
this alcohol make sneezing more likely
and we find no evidence yet that air
pollution in London p.m. to 5pm 10 and
no2 has any relationship with her but
the prevalence of her use of
antihistamines I think we will find it
but it might be a much subtler thing and
that's where the academic collaboration
comes in I think we're basically their
these are the tools that we've used
item 3 obviously and a big shout out to
anaconda and pandas are for preparing
the data and scikit-learn SQLite from
the data on the device and then hdf
local story to the data say is that else
that's us thank you very much and
whoever's on the room timing where how
long do we have Oh blimey go us ok any
questions in that case we've got a few
minutes Tim yes I'm pretty sure we've
ruled that out it is a condition for
some people I know yes all right right
so yeah one of the things we did was use
the hygrometer so I used the this one
here at one point in the winter this is
November it was raining a lot we were
drawing our washing inside he got very
damp in the house so we dried the house
out thoroughly and we kept it a
50-percent to to dry out those pesky
dust mites that might have been having a
happy environment for the few weeks that
we let it get damp and then we read
about the dust mites that oh this is
rubbish so it's great that we're getting
rid of those maybe and if they are a
problem also we're drawing out the air
which might be a problem for Emily so we
don't know I'm trying not to modify the
environment too much i'm trying to get
clean data for this for this stage
another question user
no I haven't tried putting her to sleep
either right yeah some people have noted
that it might be either the body
relaxing and you're prone and then by
sitting up you change the blood flow and
you change the air flow and if a
desensitized nasal tissue is suddenly
sensitized again it could be that it
could just be the increase in the volume
of air going through because when you
wake up you breathe more air and this is
a game while I'm keen to collaborate
with the academics because they should
know the answers to these questions and
they should have seen this in other
people and they may have insight whereas
we're just making this up as we go along
yes I'm not allowed to I cannot forbid
my wife from trying to feel less rubbish
when things are bad yeah totally yeah oh
no the confounders all over the place
here you know this is not a clean
wonderful setting I have not suggested
to my wife that I put her into an
isolated chamber for a year and see how
she reacts to things it's not going to
work but and this is I think the
interesting thing there's a number of
things that we can't easily control for
in our environment and yet we have to
live our life if you suffer from an from
a bad complaint maybe not a terminal one
but maybe some that makes your life a
bit worse than it otherwise could be why
couldn't we use these supercomputers in
our pocket and the census that are now
becoming very cheap to monitor our life
and to improve things at which point we
have to deal with the confounders and so
here part of the reason for this is to
try to get a handle on this because this
is only going to become more important
in the future I mean there's going to be
a loeffel lot of work to be done here in
the future and I figure trying to make
people's lives better is a good thing
and you can't strap them into an
isolated environment so it's gotta deal
with it have
no no again Oh yep a tablet yep sure Oh
have run various experiments on my wife
only given her migraines on a couple of
occasions and she's still open to it I
don't know she'd like the idea of
placebos but I like you thinking okay
Yeah right yeah and I don't we've
discussed this there's an exercise log
by My Fitness Pal don't because exercise
is a stressor and then there's all the
other stresses of everyday life and we
don't happening as thought about how to
log that and partly that's again with
the academics we can propose that as a
hypothesis and if they say actually that
could be totally key great we should do
something about it we're cautious about
logging too many things because there's
too much stuff we could log everything
and if we could then maybe even find
signals that a coincidental or true
signals but all these things are harder
to log and so we have to be pragmatic at
that time but I great which should be we
need to at least consider it no totally
right so absolutely we could record as
well yeah well yeah i'm not going to
conclude on those results just yet but
i'm happy enough to stand up here and
say i think it's a worry i can bust out
one of my appendix slides so here's
where i wrote a custom recursive feature
elimination method which exhaustively
tried all the features are all 84
features took out the least useful one
and then we get a new score and then try
all of them together 283 features at a
time on 50 repeats of fivefold
cross-validation taking the average and
then take it so this even high variance
even just doing that but increasingly
taking out all of the features and then
you end up getting an increasingly good
score and things are looking really good
then you pull out the last
when it drops it off to nothing and
that's fine and it turns out the last
couple of things that you pull out it's
just sneezes today and antihistamines
yesterday so they're the most consistent
features and all the rest of these are
just yo sure I mean I got rid of all of
these and I get this and I go well look
for the year I've got nearly seventy
percent accuracy when I look at it there
five-day standard deviation change of
the two day thing this is this is
garbage it is this is a feature that
coincidental rather than a predictive
feature and I believe if we got more
data outside of the cross validation
period that relationship would drop away
so I just don't trust him so you don't
get blood pressure from a wearable
device easily you still need a large
mercury band right and and there is a
limit to the Borg ification of my wife
that I can do at the moment so I would
like I would like more data right and it
won't be long before we have either
simple external devices or internal
devices of what we like 5-10 year say
but we can see this is coming people who
have diabetes have internal devices to
report their their condition into levels
to a device for the automatic release of
medication right there's a closed
feedback loop that you can embed inside
yourself to look after yourself so you
haven't got a real rely upon yourself to
get it right so this is all coming and
this is also five years ago or five
years in the future so we want want want
more of this but right now I'm limited
to how many things i can get my wife to
reliably do without getting really
annoyed with me all right okay it so
quick question then we're happy yep
no we have has a good question but she
almost always has her medication could
he stated tiny tablet rather easy to
carry so she almost always have them all
right thank you very much everyone